Mr Mercer how are you good to see you my
friend I'm good listen I'm excited about
this I have stats I want to play a game
with you okay let's go for those that
don't know Dave Mercer is the uh founder
CEO of lmax group omax group owns omax
digital along with a ton of other uh
foreign currency exchanges uh I would
argue I can say this I don't think you
can you guys are the largest or one of
the largest uh infrastructure providers
or market makers or Market providers in
foreign currencies uh you also happen to
be quite popular
um in the uh crypto world as well no
popular enough no retail all
institutions correct all right so I like
that you guys put these together I I
basically I don't pay attention to any
of the stats that lmax digital's Twitter
account tweets all month and I wait for
the monthly report and I and I go
through and I look at it and in the
month of March you guys did 20 billion
dollars in total notional volume
on you were 74 trades away 174 trades
away from 3 million trades in the month
and you traded an equivalent of 482 000
Bitcoin
and this year alone already year to date
you've done 66 billion dollars these are
like Bonkers numbers compared to most
other exchanges but it's been a slow
year though compared to sort of last
year now we needed q121 right so our
best month ever we did 60 billion we
call a billion a yard in FX right so um
sort of 60 yards is where we want to get
to you know so 20 yards for me is kind
of disappointing but you know you can't
uh change the market I guess it's been a
sort of slow start of the Year why do
you think that it's been a slower start
is it just price related is it macro
like fed policy interest rate stuff yeah
I think that's right I mean you know as
well as I do if you're looking at it
it's kind of been directionless most of
the Year okay we got sold off a bit
everyone's worried about the macro side
inflation of course you've got the uh
war in Ukraine so and Bitcoin
particularly at the moment I mean that
look the whole asset class is driven by
Bitcoin
we like to think that it's going to be a
store of value Asset we like to think
it's going to be you know digital goal
everyone talks about it but actually
it's a risk on off asset class so like
stocks if you chart the s p or the
NASDAQ versus say Bitcoin you're just
seeing the same price action just a bit
of a lag so that's meant it's been
directionless I think now
um there's dokon buying a whole bunch of
Bitcoin has helped well look from the
start of the year now we're basically
unch right so it's whatever whatever it
is now 46 000 especially unchanged in
the year we're still waiting for that
influx of real institutional money
because that's going to make it pop if
dokwon uh from Terra with only three
billion dollars I'd say only but in the
institutional world it's not really that
much money
if he can have the impact that he's had
over the last I don't know five weeks or
whatever it's been yeah when
institutions show up with real size is
Bitcoin go to a million dollars a coin
you're gonna be happy I'm not even sure
you're gonna be doing this podcast
anymore
that's all I know you're like David it's
been nice knowing you but I'm on a beach
what do you think happens though like
it's going to explode Anthony I mean
look so here's the I've said it again I
think before in your show there are 200
trillion dollars of Assets in custody
today that's a fact the three biggest
custodians in the world are the three
you know three three biggest custodian
banks are you know uh State Street Bank
of New York Mellon JP Morgan they
control a hundred trillion there are 500
institutions in the world that matter
total market cap of crypto today 2
trillion one percent of those assets in
custody
I know all these names are looking to
enter the market I know all their
customers and their investors want
access to crypto so if just five percent
of those artists in custody go into
crypto it's very simple
the market cap of the asset class has to
be 10 trillion dollars that's 5x we are
today so what happens to the price you
know as I say and you get the keys and
lock the door here
I mean I completely agree obviously uh
what I think is fascinating I was
talking to a pretty large hedge fund
manager recently and uh his perspective
on crypto was like I'm not anti-crypto I
just know what I'm good at and where I
have an advantage and that's in equities
and so I'm going to stick to investing
inequities
um but it's interesting to me help me
understand and
he knew that there was 21 million
Bitcoin
he understood the idea of Supply demand
obviously
when I started to explain the on-chained
metrics and the ability to see the
illiquidity in the market he kind of you
know he perked up a little bit yeah
right and he started to say so you
basically have like the structural
liquidity but then you have like the
actual Market liquidity and you can
start to basically uh analyze which
people have what historical holding for
selling patterns how much illiquidity
how long when did they buy what was the
pro and I was like it's all right there
on the blockchain yeah and you could
just see him being like still Equity guy
yeah but like there's more information
available here that could have better
informed various decisions and so when I
see when I take that as kind of an
anecdotal uh point from a conversation
in your guys metrics uh you break out
the average trade size by instrument
yeah and the chart that I'm looking at
uh has Bitcoin USD versus ethusd Bitcoin
USD uh pretty much since the beginning
of last year has had a much more
significant average trade size so that
strips away how many institutions that
strips away how much volume it's just
looking at when somebody trades what's
the average size why is Bitcoin so much
larger is it because the Market's larger
and people feel like there's more
liquidity or is there something else
going on 100 I mean that's that's where
the liquidity is I mean if you
you know you meet a bunch of people
asking you hey what should I buy
and you'll know a lot more coins and a
lot more assets than I will but I'm like
look if you're dipping your toe in the
water go Bitcoin it's the most liquid
asset class so someone comes to us and
they want to buy 10 bucks worth of
bitcoin 10 million dollars worth
that's relatively easy to do
you try and hit that in one clip in in
ether and you're going to move the
market and you're going to get slipped
180 200 basis points you've got to slice
and dice it you're doing smaller sizes
just that all the biggest market makers
are
trading Bitcoin first and again let's
look at it it's 40 to 50 of the value of
the total asset class so when they first
come they're making Bitcoin I think
ethereum is doing better
Salon is also doing better but it's very
thin and when you talk about that
institution of money coming in you just
see huge price gaps
which
isn't good for the asset class and it's
partly what we have to try and do at our
next group and LMX digital it's bringing
bigger better institutional market
makers to get deeper liquidity across
the asset I have a customer you know
last week literally beating me up David
look at the slippage now all I did was
buy 20 ether 20 million ether I'm like
dude this is huge you're just the
biggest in the market today
in that asset class you need to cut that
up you need to trade that in shapes of
about fifty thousand dollars
if you're lucky to get it done you can't
do it in one click he trades a bunch of
foreign exchanges with me his biggest
day in FX as me was three billion
dollars and he trades in clips of 20 30
50 million and they expect to be able to
do the same in crypto you just can't
today so let's use this hypothetical
person a real person but don't say their
name
um if they trade three billion dollars
in a day and they're doing it let's just
call it 50 million uh at a pop are they
trading to capture one two percent moves
intraday and they're like like literally
day trading uh is it a human driving
that is this all uh kind of high
frequency stuff like walk me through
what they would do in the FX world if
you trade three billion in a day and
you're trading that size what is the
goal or the trading strategy well it
depends who they are right so I kind of
have three
distinct sets of clients you've got
Banks who are basically facilitating
trades for their customers their
customers might be asset managers
portfolio managers they need to buy 100
million euros 200 million euros a
billion euros to facilitate uh rebalance
in their portfolio you've then got
brokers
a lot of broker servicing retail and
they're just back to backing that flow
and then you've got the proprietary
training firms they don't like the
terminology hft high frequency Traders
but they're just looking to gain some
Alpha and get in and out they're trying
to make markets everywhere and they're
trying to Nick
half the spread but the one thing that
underlies all of that if that's too
detailed too complex for everyone is the
smartest guys are all using our goals to
execute the trades now so even you know
who's the most famous investor in
Bitcoin I guess it's Michael Saylor you
know he's using an algo to work that
order he's got a Target price he's using
a v-wop
and by the way you can buy these on eBay
right you can buy these models if you
want to you just plug them in and you're
just trying to to have a Target price
right to let you access that so that's
really what they're all doing and no
one's pointing and clicking and so I'd
say that today 90 of all our FX volume
are done through API and done through
algorithmic Trading
so when that person comes to crypto yeah
they want to do similar size I'm
assuming uh if you can't do 50 million
dollars at a time then you can't do
three billion a day correct and
regardless of how Superior your
infrastructure technology is it's a
market Dynamic issue yeah
but
if you need it it's there so remember
I've got the biggest institutional
market makers on the street so my
biggest ever day in crypto
May last year we did 6.5 billion dollars
in crypto biggest customer oh yeah if
you do six points all right yeah but
like like what does that look like just
directionally like I'm the guy for for
us we'll fall for the customer for us
we're the guy in the middle right so
it's a couple of basis points you're
making just for every trade the retail
guy is going to recall in horror jeez
we're paying 50 basis points or 10 basis
points no I mean the institutional game
you're charging one or two basis points
by the way in foreign exchange you're
paying a 40th of a basis point to make
it clear that's the cost of trade FX
yeah why is it so cheap just because you
tell me yeah you know I'm glad crypto
came along now look you know it's it's
it's a very liquid very efficient market
again to scale that for yourself and
your listeners foreign exchange trades
seven trillion dollars every single day
seven trillion what do we think the spot
Market in crypto is a day 20 30 billion
so you know you're talking 200x
so
one basis point if I'm good at math is
six million dollars
if that's the biggest day I wish it was
six million
is that what it is 600 600k is that oh
yeah one percent six million yeah see
look we don't do public math we already
did it but like my
my question is how do other
institutional exchanges that don't have
the FX business how do they build a
business if they're only doing half a
million dollars let's call it plus or
minus in their biggest days well you
look I mean just look at their go to
their uh to their web page and say fees
and it says 10 20 30 basis points I mean
look I'm saying I'm calling this out
right now I'm saying it's too expensive
to trade crypto today if you're a
retailer if you're small but
I understand why it's that price right
because it is hard to access it yeah I
think what we do for a living is all
about providing Market access about
providing frictionless Market access to
any Market we offer
that means the price point can come down
you know that well-known name inequities
are sure it's free to trade right so the
price has gone to zero in crypto it's
hard to access it it's hard to get the
liquidity in some cases on the retail
exchanges they pay liquidity providers
and also if someone's trading in size of
you know 500 bucks like really dollars
and cents you have to have a minimum
there so that's what that's why they can
charge that but I think over time you're
going to see the price curve just look
like this it's just gonna just gonna go
down and it's gonna resemble more what
you see in equities and more you see in
foreign exchange do you think that wall
eventually race to zero similar to what
happened in equities in crypto for
retail Traders yeah look so there's a
secret out here out there which is it's
never for free there's always a spread
yeah right so a lot of guys because hey
I trade for free okay what's the Buy
price what's the sale price but for sure
as the market becomes more efficient and
that's partly we have to do at lmax I've
got to bring bigger institutions to this
Marketplace I've got to bring
better liquidity to this Marketplace
when that happens spreads will compress
and when that happens the cost to buy
and sell will also compress so yeah
you're going to see it become much more
efficient and a better market for
private investors and institutional
investors alike what have you heard from
those institutions as to why a lot of
them aren't in the market yet
look it's it's tough for them right so
again it's um
it's Market structure right
those institutions those 500 names that
really matter they need a regulatory
framework what do I mean
they need
regulate Street determinism okay these
are the rules of the game this is how I
access the market
and this is how I
don't contravene any legislation at the
moment with a lack of legislation a lack
of Regulation they run the risk that
there's no determinism and suddenly two
years down the line someone says hold on
a second you contravene this rule wait
that rule wasn't there
so that's the biggest blocker
um look up a bit self-promoting here but
we launched uh announced that we're
going to launch Futures with six group
why did we do that we can offer crypto
Futures on an FCA regulated MTF what's
an MTF it's like a swap execution
facility in the US and that can go
through a central Clearinghouse with six
group now the biggest banks
biggest Traders industry to understand
that framework so we give them a
framework we give them a ballpark that
they understand
and hopefully we give them a pragmatic
regulatory framework that allows this
asset class to grow and believe you me
this is important for everyone crypto
evangelists crypto natives retail
investors that framework's important for
everyone so that's that's the biggest
block of today
when you think about
[Music]
um
the largest institutions that aren't
participating
how many of them are doing it because
they're a founder or their uh individual
at the head of the organization likes it
or owns a lot personally versus uh their
clients that their Pension funds their
Sovereign wealth funds their foundations
are the ones pushing them to do it
so it's the fuma and it wouldn't even be
like I know you're on stage tomorrow
with a famous founder who likes it
um
but when I look at the market makers
don't call him famous let me cut them
down then we'll build them back I saw
the guy on billions trust me he's famous
um
and mostly it's because they can make
the call look to a certain extent if you
look at our Max group I'm the largest
shareholder of LMX group 2017 we first
looked at crypto said hey should we do
this I didn't have to go through a
lengthy compliance committee risk
committee board meeting to say should we
do it we just sat around the table one
day and said
let's launch lmax digital so I think the
preeminent market makers the preeminent
Traders today are guys who had that lack
of bureaucracy and were able to make
slightly autocratic decisions so I think
that's why they were first imagine if
you were in one of the largest banks
I've said this to you before but one of
them told me they're going to trade it
this year I know they'll trade it one of
the biggest banks in the world but
they've been through 26 committee
approvals so far I think they've got 30
more to go
it feels like uh the other thing that's
happening
is the individuals are becoming
institutions we were talking uh before
the show there's a uh a gentleman who
started a hedge fund three years ago
um
he put an enormous amount of money for
an individual nine figures personally in
the fun to get it started
he probably the biggest LP right he's
bigger than all the institutions are in
the fund and so it feels like as the
currency gets devalued asset prices go
up rich get richer
you now are getting in this weird world
where like
individuals are becoming institutions
and I think that like they're the ones
who transition first we've already seen
a number of family offices all those
folks all come into it
I think what becomes fascinating is like
they talk to their friends who aren't
big enough to be institutions but work
at the institutions and that's how it's
spreads it's less about the Bitcoin
Community convincing them and it's more
about I'm watching my friend sit here
and just pick up you know profits over
and over and over again with the
volatility of you know Bitcoin or crypto
markets eventually I'm saying to my
colleagues at work we got to get in this
game and it's more of a an Envy thing a
a competition thing than it is like we
have some big macro perspective on you
know interest rates and that's what's
going to lead us to bitcoin like I think
that we forget like the human psychology
of this is like my friends making money
they're making more money than me what
are they trading I'm good at trading
like I should go trade that too if they
can make that money imagine how much I
can make natural polls in these
institutions yeah I think it's fair a
lot of points in there Anthony I'll try
to remember them but look it is true
there's a lot of big names now in crypto
who started as individuals Maybe started
mining they stuck together an exchange
or a platform really quickly they
launched a purpose swap they're now
worth a lot of money and that in itself
is self-fulfilling what I would say
stepping back again you know that
Capital markets is so much bigger than
any given billionaire
in crypto today right back to that 200
trillion dollars today so what I'm
looking at is
five years hence that efficient market
structure that will mean
Bitcoin and crypto can overtake gold
goals 10 to 12 trillion dollars today
and you guess what then when you have
deeper liquidity a more efficient market
it'll be harder to make money you'll
have to actually be a really good Trader
right right now you can just sort of you
know put it all on red put it all on
black yeah right if you're a Believer
it'll become harder but it'll become
much bigger and by the way this is the
Natural Evolution of things you know I'm
old enough to remember.com not everyone
got it right not everyone backed Skype
not everyone backed Amazon or Google but
it's important that some of that
intellectual Capital moved from
traditional markets into the new one and
that's happening today and I think it's
a great thing for crypto and guess what
I also think it's great for traditional
Finance
because some of that's going to feed
back in traditional finance and make
that a better Market as well
Russia Ukraine is another topic that I
know uh probably is having an impact on
your business what's going on there
obviously when you have some sort of
conflict commodity prices currencies the
whole kind of macro engine starts to
move what have you seen both in the
non-crypto and the crypto party business
so I think first and foremost
the hardest bit has been the
humanitarian impact I mean this is a
human catastrophe catastrophe and
people say oh you were dealt three
conflicts before we haven't This is war
in Europe right this is war with a
nuclear superpower that is interwoven
throughout the fabric of society
throughout the fabric of capital markets
you know I've got Russians and
ukrainians
sitting in my tech team on my desk every
institution does this is tough to deal
with
but but
we're in capital markets okay so our job
is to deliver efficient Capital markets
at all time credit crises banking crises
pandemic the atrocity of War you need to
have efficient Capital markets right
Goods still need to be paid for so
that's what we're trying to do now
so let's park the humanitarian bit for a
moment crypto
has had a great period
why again you've seen
the robustness and the resilience of
this asset class we discussed the price
action this is really positive
you've seen the crypto
can be used for good right frictionless
borderless payments again you know
people wanting to contribute all over
the world in crypto to that
guess what
we've it's spurred The Regulators into
action you know it's no fluke that
suddenly President Biden issues an
executive order that Senator Warren
tables a sanctions Bill the ECB European
Central Bank the bank of England
suddenly accelerate their crypto
Frameworks that was good and probably
the the last thing is
it's debunked the miss everyone told me
hey and look at it look what happened in
the U.S crypto is going to be a sanction
Buster incorrect you know you knew this
I knew this
how can they circumvent the sanctions
let's look at it AML guidelines worked
well
it's quite hard to buy stuff with even
Bitcoin today I've never tried to buy
Munitions or tanks right or or jets but
I'm guessing that's pretty tough and
it's probably easier with a suitcase of
dollars than it is Bitcoin
oh guess what everyone
Bitcoin and crypto is pretty transparent
have a look at the blockchain
and lastly
President Putin didn't believe in it why
didn't he believe in it he couldn't
control it so he spent no time
developing crypto so I think those myths
have been completely debunked so overall
it's been a very positive period again
like the start of the pandemic right a
positive period for crypto and for this
asset class yeah Joe John what questions
you guys got
I'm curious to talk about so Bitcoin
specifically a lot of these institutions
are rumored to want to get access to it
what about ethereum and son are you
seeing demand for those as well sure but
look
ultimately comes down to liquid asset
classes you know I'm in foreign exchange
um Euro dollars the the biggest threat
of asset class
um biggest head instrument so any given
day euro dollar is going to make up 30
of all the FX trading that's just it so
Bitcoin today is going to make up
40 50 so Solana yes it's coming ethereum
yes it's coming but the most liquidity
still gravitates to
um to the number one in the asset class
so it's up I'd say to the
the founders the engineers behind the
other coins you've got to keep proving
that point
right the argument is ah Bitcoin for
payments ethereum for utility okay well
you've got to start showing us the
utility and the same as Solana
right if you want that to trade more if
you want that price to go up if you want
to have more liquidity you've got to
keep proving the utility of those coins
yeah and you don't think Bitcoin has to
prove that
I think it's proven
for me I you know the more you look at
it the more you research it bitcoin's
proven
well it's been around what 13 14 years
now I don't know how long Satoshi
thought about it before he created it
it's proven and it's been through the
Peaks and troughs you know you know I
said it I've said it before look at
their you know March 21 was it March 20
the start of the pandemic every asset
class got sold off
oil traded below zero Bitcoin shot said
it was going to zero it didn't
right it found a level and it bounced
back and it traded what 64 000 at the
end of last year now trading forty six
thousand this is now a robust asset so I
don't need to get anything anything left
to proven
um
you know you're not seeing many
level one protocol breaches right with
this asset I'm I'm as comfortable
holding that
as I am holding Fang stocks or holding
gold in my portfolio and I think that's
why it will go from strength to strength
and the others still have a lot
waterproof when it comes to your
business specifically L Max right how do
you guys think or project that crypto as
a percentage of your business will look
years from now I'm assuming it's still a
smaller part giving your head start in
FX and shot but where do you think that
this goes does it become a meaningful
portion or just talk me through kind of
your thought process there
it could become 50 of it so why do I
think that so we trade over 100
instruments
in foreign currency so we trade you
wouldn't believe it I'm sure you never
want to trade it we trade Norwegian
krona against against Swedish krona who
wants to trade that well guess what the
Scandinavians do right so
um but at the moment most things are
against dollar right so the s p is
called in dollar nasdaq's cutter than
the dollar gold dollar a little bit of
gold Euro but actually 90 of it is gold
dollar dollar gold sorry for any
currency guys that are out there
um so what happens with crypto at the
moment it's you're trading Bitcoin
dollar ethereum dollar
you're going to start trading Bitcoin s
p
Ong gold
Bitcoin Swedish krona Norwegian Krona we
have it right now in the crypto space Oh
it's Bitcoin dollar David you also have
um usdc it's the same guys don't worry
about it it's the same order book right
so I can actually merge the dollar order
book with the usdc order book so I think
it could become a lot right now first
step let's get past gold gold would be
five percent of my book
um but I really think
as we start to accept certainly the
currency related or the currency like
cryptos that's what I think Bitcoin is
I think you'll see that traded against
everything we're launching an exchange
in Singapore
first time ever within LMX group we'll
have an fx exchange and a crypto
exchange on the same infrastructure
under the same license right the uh our
customers love that
right one account trade Bitcoin trade
Euro trade gold trade NASDAQ
how good is that going to be for the
asset class again and hopefully of
course good for our Max group of course
you get
one magic wish
in the institutional world for Bitcoin
you wave magic wand it happens what's
the thing you wish for
I want a regulatory framework
um in the United States
and the United Kingdom tomorrow so that
the biggest banks in the world can just
go trade the spot and the future
together
because at the moment Banks can't really
trade the spot they want to trade the
future in the derivative
within our Max group they can trade the
spot on our Max digital and the future
on our Max exchange so that's what I
want to happen and actually I think it
is happening but
it takes time with these legislators
these regulators
you think it's that important that's
like the number one thing the number one
thing if you want this Market to grow
Anthony we need regulatory determinism
yeah that's it
it's all very well there's only so big
this Market can be built on retail and
private investors correct I'm very happy
when they keep growing and they keep
doing well and making more money but you
want that weight of money I want those
500 institutions in the space correct
they just need to know the rules of the
game so let's get moving let's do it and
you know no apologies for this
offshore regulation is not the way
Island regulation is not the way we all
have to do it to a certain extent while
we're growing we need the leaders yeah
you need the cftc the SEC the fed the
bank of England the FCA the mas and
Singapore you need these guys to create
the framework right because it's a
pragmatic approach again you want those
Pension funds and those asset managers
to be able to access the market when
they access the market this thing is
just going to go pop up
I ain't gonna say nothing else after
that ending
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or find out more about omax
it's pretty easy right lmx.com or
lmxdigital.com and I'm david.murser at
either of those we gotta get uh we gotta
get you Tweeting more
do you know yeah I don't think people
just not not that much fun am I you know
I'm sort of I'm sort of the status quo
I'm just a little bit you know the old
gray head guy where's your cover photo
from that one that's the North Pole so
I've got a world record for the most
northern gamer rugby uh at the North
Pole so it's almost fast it's quite fun
when you uh speak to any Canadian I
always say them I bet you I've been
further north than your country and then
you have and they're like really like
yeah I thought you've been North Pole I
got two questions how did you get there
and what's the weather like up there oh
I nearly swore
um it's uh
bloody cold but then again the guys in
Chicago kind of looked at me look at me
like yeah it's not that cold yeah what
was it David minus 35 minus 40. yeah
it's kind of like a normal day in
February for us
um a whole bunch of planes from London
and then I tracked 130 miles put in a
sledge with a bunch of buddies and um
hoping it would all be over very soon
you played the rugby game outside yeah
in shorts
was that a requirement for the world
record or you're just crazy
I'm from Belfast and all the uh all the
English guys were like
you're Irish you have to wear shorts I'm
like yeah hell I'm wearing shorts and uh
but with the setup it was quite
interesting right we had to set up the
we had to set up the the pitch we had to
put bags full of of
um snow down so the plane could land to
bring the kit to set up the pitch we had
to put the posts up draw the lines the
whole thing and one of my great
marketing guys at the time he bought a
brought a drone over to take the to take
a video of the match
batteries Frozen within a minute and a
half so we didn't get much footage
that is awesome now now I gotta think of
something that we can go do that's not
at the North I hate the cold
maybe I'll go somewhere where's the
hottest place in the world it is Sahara
you don't do the South Pole that's my
that's that's on my bucket list is to do
the South Pole
um maybe you can play some rugby there
now I've ticked them both off
the hot you can do that my CEO he's from
he's from Africa he likes he likes the
heat I struggle with that
you heat is way better than cold no you
you like like you know 90 degree weather
no you say that it's hot nah how's that
130 degree weather oh it's chilling all
right we're good don't worry they eat
the cold though that's not my thing mine
is 10 degrees and stuff like that was
bad enough I mean I played golf for the
buddy of mine
um actually he runs LMX exchange
um on the FX side in Scottsdale Arizona
I went hey this is really cheap hotel
the golf is cheap
he was yes great you love it it was 120
degrees on nearly I mean
in Miami what happens is uh during the
summer we always go golfing because it's
cheaper it's no competition for tee
times anything we're not good at golf
but it's fun whatever uh the second you
start getting into the fall you see the
prices jump yeah because it's getting
cooler right so they know all right it's
actually the inverse most places in the
summer is more expensive here it's the
opposite because it's just hot as [ __ ]
out correct not not Scottsdale is
probably even worse than uh than here
all right my friend thank you so much
for doing this we uh we enjoyed it uh
I'm hoping for you that uh 60 billion
dollar months come back six yards that
means 60 yards there you go that means
uh that's good for everyone I'll come
back and do 100 yards in any any given
month that's the goal a hundred yeah so
a 5x from here yeah yeah by the end of
the year it's open [ __ ] it